Good morning, everybody.
I'm Anitha Vijayakumar,
Technical Program Manager for TensorFlow.
Welcome. Good morning to all of you.
It's really exciting to be here
with all of you today,
and welcome to the 2018
TensorFlow Developer Summit.
We have a packed day
filled with lots of interesting talks,
and some really cool demos.
We hope you enjoy it as much as we do.
As you know, we are together embarking
on a transformative journey
in the field of machine learning
and artificial intelligence.
Problems that were impossible
or too complex are now possible
to solve using this technology.
This field is unleashing new frontiers
and substantially changing many aspects
of our lives in a meaningful way.
We’ve already seen great
advantages in many different areas
with machine learning.
Some examples are:
In the field of astronomy,
hunting for new planets is no easy task.
These planets are small, cold,
dark objects compared to their host star.
Researchers and astrophysicists
have analyzed large amounts
of data from the Kepler mission,
and by using machine learning
have discovered a brand new planet
called the Kepler-90i,
making it the only 8-planet solar system
that we know of in our universe
other than our own.
In healthcare, we have discovered
that looking at scans
of the human eye,
machine learning can assess
a person’s risk
for cardiovascular diseases.
Just imagine if the screening
can be done with a mobile device,
how profound the effect will be.
Suddenly the whole world
will have access to rapid, easy,
affordable non-invasive
screening for heart diseases,
saving lots of lives.
In aviation, trajectory prediction
is a critical component
to ensuring that aircrafts can fly safely
and efficiently in crowded spaces.
Engineers and air traffic
controllers in Europe are using
machine learning to predict
the trajectory of a flight
through the air spaces of Belgium,
Luxembourg, Germany, and the Netherlands.
This has more than 1.8 million
flights per year and is one of the most
dense and complex air spaces
in the world.
In dairy farming, we know
that a cow’s health is vital
to the survival of the dairy industry.
And folks at [inaudible], our company
in the Netherlands wondered
if they can use machine learning
to track the health of cows
and be able to provide insight
to farmers and veterinarians on actions
to be taken to ensure
we have happy, healthy cows
that are high-yielding.
So we now have happy cows
not only from California
but also the Netherlands.
Fighting climate change:
Fighting climate change
and protecting our forests,
we believe the technology
has a huge role to play.
A group of engineers
and scientists have built
real-time detection and alerting
mechanisms to detect logging of trees.
They listen to real-time data
from chainsaw sounds,
from trucking sounds,
from logging sounds,
and machine learning is fighting
deforestation and protecting
our precious rainforests.
In music: There are many machine learning
algorithms using deep neural networks
that can learn the characteristics
of sounds and create completely new music
based on these characteristics.
In arts and culture:
You can even search
if you have a long-lost twin
from the past by looking at oil paintings
using apps that are based on machine
learning. How cool is that?
At Google, we are an AI first company
and every product is being fundamentally
impacted and changed by machine learning,
be it the popular Google Home,
or the Pixel, or Search, or Youtube,
or even Maps.
Do you know what is fascinating
in all of these examples?
TensorFlow is at the forefront of them,
making it all possible,
a machine learning platform
that can solve challenging problems
for all of us.
Join us on this incredible
journey to make TensorFlow powerful,
scalable, and the best machine learning
platform for everybody.
I now invite Rajat, Director
of Engineering of TensorFlow,
to tell us more about this. Thank you.
(applause)
Hello everyone. Good morning.
Thanks, Anita.
So let’s a look
at what we’ve been doing
over the last two years.
It’s been really amazing,
with lots of new releases.
We’ve seen the popularity
of TensorFlow really grow
over the last two years.
Especially over the last year,
we’ve focused on making
TensorFlow easy to use,
and with the release of high-level APIs
like tf.data and tf.keras,
and new programming paradigms
like Eager Execution,
really continue to make that easier.
Earlier this year, we hit the milestone
of 11 million downloads.
We are really excited to see
how much users are using this
and how much impact
it’s having in the world.
So here’s a map showing self-identified
locations of folks on GitHub
that have started TensorFlow.
And you can see that it goes
all the way up to the Arctic Circle
of [inaudible] Norway
and all the way down to Deception Island,
which is part of Antarctica.
In fact, TensorFlow is used in every
single time zone in the world.
An important part of any open-source
project are the contributors themselves.
You know, the community is
made of the people
who make this project successful.
I’m excited to see over a thousand
contributors from outside Google
who are making contributions
not just by improving code
but also by helping the rest
of the community by answering questions,
responding to queries, and so on.
Our commitment to this community
is by sharing our direction in a roadmap,
inviting public participation on design
direction, and by creating SIGs that help
focus collaboration on the key needs,
like built-in packaging of TensorBoard.
And we’ll be talking more about this
in detail later this afternoon.
Today we are launching
a new TensorFlow blog.
They’ll be sharing work by the team
and the community on this blog,
and we would like to invite you
to participate in this as well.
We’re also launching
a new YouTube channel
for TensorFlow that brings
together all the great content
that’s been created for TensorFlow.
Again, all of these are for the community
to really help build and communicate.
All day today, we’ll be sharing a number
of posts from the blog
and videos on the channel.
The talks you’re hearing here will be
made available there as well,
along with lots of conversations
and interviews with the speakers.
To make reuse and sharing easier,
today we are launching TensorFlow Hub.
This library of model components
is easily integrated into your models
with just a single line of code.
Now again, it goes back to really
making things easy for you.
Machine learning is important
and powerful, as you saw.
We care about bringing it
to more and more people.
As part of this effort,
we recently released
the Machine Learning Crash Course,
focused on introducing this
to a much broader audience.
The same course that’s trained thousands
of Googlers in machine learning
and allows us to integrate them now
into everything we build,
is now available to everyone.
TensorFlow started as a library
for numerical computation,
with a focus on deep learning
and neural networks.
Since the early release,
it’s grown to include
a very rich collection
of machine learning algorithms.
It includes popular algorithms
like linear regressions and decision trees
commonly used for many
structured data classification problems.
There’s also a very broad collection
of state-of-the-art tools
for stats and basic analysis
in the TF public library,
and several new additions
are being released today.
You can check out the blog post
and website for more details.
As I mentioned earlier, one of the big
key focus points for us is to make
TensorFlow easy to use, and towards
that we’ve been pushing on simpler APIs,
easier to use and making them
more intuitive.
At the lowest level, our focus is
to consolidate a lot of the APIs we have
and make it easier to build
these models and train them.
At the lowest level, the TensorFlow APIs
are really, really flexible, and they let
users build anything they want to.
With Eager Execution, these same APIs
are now easier to use.
TensorFlow also contains
a full implementation of Keras.
TF Keras contains
building blocks like layers
to build models to make it easier
to do that and offers
lots of utilities to train them as well.
Keras works with both Graph
and Eager Execution as well.
For Distributed Execution,
we provide Estimators,
so you can take your models
and combine them with estimators
to distribute them across machines.
You can also build estimators
from the Keras layers or models.
And finally, we provide
premade estimators, a library
of ready-to-go implementations
of common machine learning algorithms.
So let’s take a look at how this works.
So first you would often define
your model, and this is a nice easy way
to define your model.
It shows a convolution model here,
with just a few lines here.
Now, once you have defined that,
often you’d want to do
some input processing, so in this case,
you load your data set from files.
And we have a great API tf.data
that was introduced in 1.4 that makes
it easy for you to process inputs
while still allowing us to do lots
of optimizations behind the scenes.
And you’ll see a lot more detail
on this later today as well.
Once you have the model
and the input data,
you can put them together
by iterating all the datasets,
computing gradients,
and updating the parameters themselves.
As you can see here, you really just
need a few lines of Python
to put these together.
And in fact, it runs just
as Python does, and you can use
your Python debugger to debug that
and solve problems as well.
Of course, you can do it
in even fewer lines by just using
the pre-defined utilities
that we have with Keras.
In this case, it executes the model
as a graph with all
the additional optimizations
that come with it.
Now, this is great for a single
machine or a single device.
Now, often, given the high
heavy computation needs
for deep learning and machine learning,
we want to use more than one accelerator
or GPU or machines themselves.
So for that we have estimators.
Taking the same model
that you’ve defined, the same data sets
that you have, you can build
an estimator and really use that to train
across this cluster or across
the multiple devices on a single machine.
That’s great.
Why not use a cluster?
Why just use a single box if you can
actually train faster with that?
This picture shows a TPU part used
for training ML models at scale.
And again, the focus is to really take
everything you’ve been doing
and just build a TPU estimator
that allows you to scale that same model
across this entire super computer.
And then, finally,
once you’ve trained that model,
you can use that one line
at the bottom to export that
for deployment itself.
So, you know,
deployment is important.
You often do that in data centers.
But more and more,
we are seeing the need to deploy this
on phones and other devices as well.
And so for that,
we have TensorFlow Lite.
The model we just exported,
we have a script to convert that
to a custom format
that’s designed for devices,
that’s lightweight, and it’s really
faster to get started with.
And then once you have that format,
you can include that in your application,
integrate TensorFlow Lite
with a few lines here, and get going.
You basically have an application
that can do ML predictions
and include ML in whatever task
you want to perform.
So TensorFlow runs not just on many
platforms but in many languages as well.
Today I’m excited to add
Swift to the mix.
And it brings with it a fresh
approach to machine learning.
Don’t miss the talk
by Chris Lattner this afternoon
that covers exciting details
of how we are enriching this platform.
JavaScript is a language
that’s synonymous with the web
development community.
I’m excited to announce TensorFlow.JS.
It’s bringing machine learning
to this growing community
of exciting web developers.
So let’s take a brief look at this.
It brings the same TensorFlow operations
that you’re used to into JavaScript
for you-- you can call them just as plain
JavaScript code-- along with full fledged
layers API on top.
It also includes full support
for TensorFlow and Keras models,
so you can pick
the most appropriate development
and deployment environment
that works for you.
So you can start in one place
and go to the other,
whichever way you want.
And under the covers, these APIs
are accelerated in the browser via WebGL,
and then the Node.js support
is coming soon,
which will give you the power
of all of TensorFlow
to accelerate on CPUs
and GPUs as well.
And with that, I would like to invite
Megan Kacholia, Engineering Director
of Google Brain, who leads our
performance efforts, to talk a bit more
about how TensorFlow does performance.
Thank you.
All right. Thanks, Rajat.
So performance across all platforms
is critical to TensorFlow’s success.
First, I want to take
a quick step back
and just talk about some
of the things we think about
when we’re measuring
and assessing TensorFlow’s performance.
One of the things we try to do is focus
on real-world data and time-to-accuracy.
It’s really important to have
reproducible benchmarks.
We want to make sure
those benchmarks
are actually realistic
of the workloads and types of things
that users like you
are actually doing
on a day-to-day basis.
Another thing like Rajat
talked about is that we want
to make sure we have clean APIs.
And we don’t want to have a fast version
and a pretty version of something;
the fast version is the pretty version.
And so all of these APIs
that we’re talking about
that we’re going to be talking
about through various talks
throughout the day today.
These are the things you can use
to get the best performance
out of TensorFlow
so that you don’t have to worry about
which one is fast, which one is pretty.
Use the pretty one; it is fast!
You’ll hear about tf.data
from Derrick right after the keynote,
as well as distribution strategy
from Igor later today.
And these are just some
great examples of things we’ve been
pushing on to ensure
good performance and clean APIs.
So in general we want to ensure
that you have great performance,
regardless of what type
of platform you might
be making use of.
Whether it’s a large data center,
like what’s shown here, or maybe
you’re using something
like what’s shown on the image here.
You have a GPU or CPU box under
your desk, maybe you’re making
use of a cloud platform, or mobile
or an embedded device.
Regardless of the type of hardware
you’re making use of,
we want to make sure
that TensorFlow performs well
across all of them.
So now getting into some numbers,
because what is a performance
talk if I don’t show you slides
of numbers?
So first let’s look at things
on the mobile side.
So this is highlighting
TensorFlow Lite performance.
So TensorFlow Lite
we initially released last fall.
And there’s going to be a talk giving
a lot more detail just about how it works
and the things we were thinking of when
making it later today by Sarah.
But I wanted to call out just here
the speedups we see in inference.
So a 3x inference speedup when using
TensorFlow Lite Quantized versus standard
TensorFlow Lite for some
of the models called out here.
And again, it’s critical
to have strong performance
regardless of what platform
you’re working on,
and we’re really excited to be able to see
these gains in mobile.
Looking past mobile, just beyond,
there are a number
of companies in the hardware space
which continues to expand.
The contributions that come out
of the collaborations that we have
with these companies,
the contributions they give back
to TensorFlow and back
to the community at large,
are critical to making sure
that TensorFlow performs well
on these specific platforms for the
users that each group really cares about.
One of the first ones I want
to highlight is Intel.
The Intel MKL-DNN library
which is open-sourced,
and it’s highly optimized for TensorFlow.
So by making use of this open-source
library, we’re able to achieve a 3x
interference speedup
on various Intel platforms.
I’ve called out Broadwell
and Skylake here
as well as see great scaling
efficiency on training.
And again,
this is one of those things
that really highlights
how important it is
to have strong collaborations
with different folks
in the community.
And we’re really excited
to be able to see things like this
that can go back to all the users.
I wanted to call out a few
of the collaborations we’ve had
with NVIDIA as well.
So one of the first things
that we’re excited about is TensorRT.
TensorRT is an inference optimizer
and a runtime for GPU platforms.
We’ve been collaborating very closely
with NVIDIA on TensorRT.
TensorRT has been around
for a little while,
but with the TensorFlow 1.7 release
we now have native support
for TensorRT built in.
That means you can get low
latency, high throughput inference.
So here you can see an 8x inference
speedup when making use of TensorRT
versus just using Native FP32
with standard TensorFlow.
So it’s great, again, to see these types
of collaborations that can be done
and the contributions come back
and the great numbers that can
be delivered by it.
Looking past inference
and going on to some
of the training things.
So mixed precision training
is really important.
As faster and more
powerful hardware comes out,
some of it is optimized such that if you
use mixed-precision or FP16 support,
that’s how you’ll get the best out
of that hardware.
One example of this
is the Tesla V100 that NVIDIA has.
So we’ve been working closely
to make sure that we have this strong
mixed-precision training support,
so that way you can get the best
performance out of that hardware.
So here you can see
a 3.5x training speedup;
this is on an 8xTesla V100 box.
And you can see
just the performance improvements
when you move
to mixed-precision training versus
just using standard TensorFlow.
Scaling efficiency is really
important as well.
Obviously we want to make sure
TensorFlow performs well.
Maybe you have a single GPU,
but it should keep going
regardless of how many things
that you throw at it.
So we want to make sure
that, again, looking at examples
for real-world data as well as
synthetic data, it’s great to benchmark
on synthetic data, but it’s very important
to make sure real-world use cases
actually perform as we expect as well.
Here we’re showing 90% scaling efficiency
with real data, 95%
with synthetic data, and this is again
on DGX-1, so an NVIDIA, V100 box
that has between one and eight GPUs.
And you can see the scaling here.
But this is something
that we care a lot about
and you’re actually going
to hear more about how to get easier
scaling efficiency by making use of some
of our internal APIs later today as well.
Moving on to cloud frameworks.
I want to talk a little about cloud TPUs.
Cloud TPU was launched
in beta in February,
just a month and a half ago.
This is Google’s V2 TPU, so it’s designed
from the ground up for machine learning
workloads, and it’s available
via Google’s cloud platform
like I mentioned.
It’s really exciting to look
at some of the numbers here.
This picture is actually showing a device,
and on a single device you’re able to get
180 teraflops of computation.
But it’s not just about the compute power,
it’s about what you can
actually do on this.
It doesn’t really matter if you have
amazing compute power,
but you can’t run the types
of models that you want.
So I want to highlight
the types of reference models
that we’ve already open-sourced
that are available today,
as well as a bunch more types of models
that are coming soon.
Again, just to highlight
the breadth of things that you
can run on this type of hardware
and get great performance,
as well as great accuracy.
We actually have
an internal team that is continually
making sure that these models
perform well, they perform fast,
and that they also are training
to accuracy in the expected
amount of time.
So it’s not just about putting
the model out there
and open-sourcing it
and saying “here go with it,”
it’s about making sure it actually works
as the community would expect it to work.
Again, some numbers because what good
is it if I don’t show any numbers
in the performance talk?
One of the numbers here I want
to call out on this slide is just that
for cloud TPUs the cost to train ImageNet
to 76% accuracy is under $85.
And we think it’s really exciting to be able
to see what you can achieve
by making use of this platform.
If you want more numbers
than what’s shown here,
you can definitely take a look
at the DAWNBench entry
that cloud TPU submitted
for the ImageNet training.
One final exciting thing I want
to call out about cloud TPUs
is availability of pods,
which will be coming later this year.
So what’s a pod?
A pod is actually 64 of the devices
like I showed earlier
all wired up together
and you get about 11.5 petaflops
of computation in a pod.
So that’s a lot of compute power
that is going to be available in this.
And what can you do
with that compute power?
One of the things that the team
has been pushing on is training ResNet-50
on a cloud TPU pod to accuracy
in less than 15 minutes.
So we’re very excited
to be able to see what can be done
with this type of hardware,
and just the amazing speed that you
can get that wasn’t possible before.
So Rajat’s talked about the APIs
and the ease of use and things
we’re focusing on, I’ve given
you some fun numbers.
But what happens when
you put it together?
What can TensorFlow actually do?
So I want to invite Jeff Dean,
who’s the leader of the Brain team,
to come up and talk a bit more about
how TensorFlow addresses real problems.
- All you!
- Thanks!
Thanks, Megan.
So I think one
of the really remarkable things
about machine learning is its capacity
to solve real problems in the world.
And we’ve seen tremendous
progress in the last few years.
In 2008, though,
the U.S. National Academy of Engineering
put out this list of Grand Engineering
Challenges that they were hoping would
be solved by the end of the 21st century.
It’s 14 different challenges.
And I think it’s a really
nice list of things
we should be aspiring
to work on as a society.
If we solved all these problems,
our planet would be healthier,
people would live longer,
they would be happier,
and generally things would be better.
I think machine learning is actually
going to help us in all of these things,
some in small ways where you see
machine learning influencing
our understanding of chemical molecules
and so on, some in very major ways.
So I’m going to talk about
two of these today,
but I think machine learning
will actually be a key to helping us
attack all of these different areas.
The two I’m going to talk about
are engineering the tools
of scientific discovery
and advancing health informatics.
So first, engineering the tools
for scientific discovery.
You know, clearly machine learning
is going to be a big component of what
we do to solve some of these challenges
and TensorFlow itself you can think
of as a tool for helping us engineer
some of these discoveries.
But one of the things
that I think is really important
is that there’s a lot more
opportunity for machine learning
than there is machine learning
expertise in the world.
The way you solve a machine learning
problem today is:
you have some data,
you have some computation,
maybe GPUs or TPUs or CPUs or whatever,
and then you have
a machine learning expert.
Someone who’s taken a graduate
class in machine learning,
someone who’s downloaded
TensorFlow and is familiar enough
to play around with it.
But that’s a pretty small set
of people in the world.
And then you stir all of this together,
and you get a solution hopefully.
So the unfortunate thing about that
is there’s probably tens
of thousands of organizations
in the world today that are actually
effectively using machine learning
in production environments and really
making use of it to solve problems.
But there’s probably tens of millions
of organizations in the world that have
data in electronic form that could
be used for machine learning
but don’t really have the internal
expertise and skills.
So one of the things we’re excited
about is how can we make machine
learning much easier to use so that you
don’t need nearly as much expertise
to apply it.
So can we use computation
to replace a lot of the need
for that machine learning expertise.
So we’ve been working on a suite
of techniques that we call Auto ML.
Neural Architecture Search is one
example of this.
One of the things that
a machine learning expert does
is they sit down and they decide
for a particular problem what kind
of model structure they’re going
to use for this problem.
Is it going to be
a ResNet 50 architecture,
is it going to be a 9-layer CMN
with these kinds of filter sizes,
and so on.
It turns out that you can
use machine learning to optimize
a controller that proposes machine
learning models.
And so you can actually
have the controller propose
machine learning models,
train those models on the problem
you care about, see which ones
work well and which ones don’t,
and use that feedback signal
as a reinforcement learning signal
for the model-generating model.
It can sort of steer it towards models
that are working well for particular
kinds of problems, and away from
the part of space where those models
don’t seem to work very well.
And if you repeat this a lot of times,
you can actually get really powerful
high-quality models.
And they look a little weird.
So this is not something
a human machine learning expert
would sit down and construct,
but it has characteristics of things
we know that human machine learning
experts have discovered are helpful.
So if you think of the ResNet
architecture, it has skip connections;
it’ll allow you to skip every other layer.
So these more organic looking
connections are the same
fundamental idea, which is you
want to allow input data to flow
more directly to the output
without necessarily going through
as much computational layers.
The interesting thing is AutoML
actually does quite well here.
This is a graph showing computational
cost versus accuracy for ImageNet.
Every dot here shows you different
kinds of tradeoffs there.
And generally as you extend
more computation,
you get higher accuracy.
Every dot here is the work
of years of cumulative effort
by top machine learning
researchers and computer
vision experts in the world.
And if you look at AutoML,
you actually get better
accuracy and better
computational tradeoffs
than all of those kinds of models.
That’s true both at the high
end where you care about upmost
accuracy and don’t care that much
about computational budget,
but it’s also true at the low end
where you have very lightweight models
where you care about very low
computational costs and high accuracy.
So that’s pretty exciting and I think
this is a real opportunity
to use more computation to solve real
machine learning problems in a much
more automated way so that we can solve
more problems more quickly.
And we’ve actually released this
in collaboration with a cloud group
at Google as a product that customers
can use for solving their own computer
vision problems and obviously we want
to broaden it out from beyond
just computer vision to lots
of other kinds of categories of problems.
Okay, Advance Health Informatics.
So machine learning and healthcare
is going to be a really impactful
combination.
One of the lay areas
that we’ve been working on
is a variety of different
medical imaging problems, including one
problem in ophthalmology where you’re
trying to look at an image like this
and diagnose whether that image
shows signs of diabetic retinopathy.
This is a serious
degenerative eye disease;
400 million people are at risk
of this around the world,
and it’s very treatable
if it’s caught in time.
But if it’s not caught in time,
you can actually suffer vision loss.
In many parts of the world,
there just aren’t enough
ophthalmologists
to inspect these images.
So we’ve done work,
and with the work that we published
at the very end of 2016, we showed
that we had a model that was on par
with board-certified ophthalmologists.
And since then we’ve been continuing
to work on this and we’ve changed
how we label our training data;
we’ve gotten a retinal specialist
to label the training data rather than
general ophthalmologists, and now
we actually have a model that is on par
with retinal specialists.
This is a much higher standard of care,
and we’re pretty excited about this
because this means
you can bring this and deliver this
to lots of places around the world.
But more interestingly,
I’m going to tell you a little tale
of scientific discovery.
So we had a new person
join the retinopathy team.
And as a warm-up exercise, Lily Pang,
who leads some of this work,
said to the new person, “Hey,
why don’t you go off and see if you
can predict age and gender
from these images?”
And she thought maybe you can predict
age within a couple of decades,
and you definitely shouldn’t
be able to predict gender,
so your AUC should be 0.5.
So the person went off and came back
a little while later and they said,
“I can predict gender
with an AUC of 0.7."
And Lily was like, “Hmm…
that’s weird. That must be wrong.
Why don’t you go off
and come back later,
and just double-check everything."
So they come back,
and they said, “My AUC is now 0.85.”
And so that got us thinking,
and we investigated what other
kinds of things we could predict
from these retinal images.
And it turns out that you can predict
a variety of different things
that are indicative
of cardiovascular health.
Your age and gender are signs
of cardiovascular health,
as are things like your hemoglobin
levels, lots of things like this.
We now actually have a new non-invasive
test for cardiovascular health.
Normally you have to draw
blood and do lab tests for this,
but now we can do this just
from an image, which is pretty cool.
We’re also doing a bunch of work
on predictive tasks for healthcare.
So given a patient’s medical record,
can we predict the future?
This is something doctors want to do;
you want to understand how your
patient’s going to progress
and you want to be able to answer
lots of questions: "Will the patient
be readmitted if I release them
from the hospital now?
What are the most likely diagnoses
I should be thinking about?
What tests should be considered
for this patient right now?"
Lots of questions like that.
And we’ve been collaborating
with several healthcare organizations
to work on de-identified medical records
to see if we can predict
these kinds of things.
And in January, we posted
a mini author archives paper,
and we looked at a lot of these
different types of tasks.
I'll highlight just one of them here,
which is predicting which patients
are most at risk for mortality.
And using this, we’re able to actually
predict which patients are most
seriously at risk 24 hours earlier
than the clinical base lines
that are currently in use.
And so that really means the doctors
get 24 hours of advance notice
to really pay attention to those
patients that are critically ill
and really need their close attention
and close watching.
So this is indicative of what machine
learning can do for this kind of field.
In general, the Google Brain team’s
mission is to make machines intelligent
and then use that ability to improve
people’s lives.
I think these are good examples of where
there’s real opportunity for this.
I’m going to close with a bit of a story.
So when I was five years old,
I lived in northwestern Uganda
for a year, and the local crop there
is a root called cassava.
And I was five, so I’d like to go out
and help people pick cassava.
But it turns out that machine learning and
cassava have a cool twist together.
Please roll the video.
♪ (music) ♪
(David Hughes) Cassava’s a really
important crop.
It provides for over 500 million
Africans every day.
(Amanda Ramcharan) When all
other crops fail,
farmers know that they can rely on their
cassava plants to provide them food.
(Latifa Mrisho) There are several diseases
that affect cassava, and these diseases
make the root inedible.
It is very crucial to actually control
and manage these diseases.
(David) So we’re trying to use machine
learning to respond to those diseases.
(Amanda) And TensorFlow is the best
foundation for our solutions.
The app that we’ve designed
can diagnose multiple diseases.
It’s called nuru,
Swahili for light,
the light that farmers
can use to see their problems
and find solutions.
You wave your phone over
a specific leaf, look at it,
and if it has a symptom, the box will
pop up saying you have this problem.
When you get a diagnosis,
we have an option for you
to get advice and learn
about the best management practices.
The object detection that we use
through TensorFlow relies
upon our team annotating images.
(Amanda) We’ve collected over 5,000
high-quality images of different cassava
diseases for this project.
We use a single shot detector model
on the mobile net architecture.
It’s able to make predictions
in less than one second.
(Pete McCloskey) Instead of having
to implement thousands of lines of code,
TensorFlow provides a library
of functions that allow us
to build architectures in much less time.
(Amanda) We need something
that can be deployed on a phone
without any connection.
TensorFlow is able to shrink
these neural networks to be able to fit
on your mobile device.
(Pete) The human input
is absolutely critical.
We’re really building something
that augments your experience
and makes you better at your job.
(Amanda) So with AI tools and machine
learning, you can improve the yields,
you can protect your crops, and you can
have a much more reliable source of food.
(David) AI offers the prospect
to fundamentally transform the life
of hundreds of millions of farms
around the world.
(Latifa) You can see a product that can
actually make someone’s life better.
This is kind of revolutionary.
Pretty cool! I think we have some
members of the Penn State
and IITA teams from Tanzania here today,
so if you could all stand up or wave.
And I’m sure they’d be happy
to chat with you.
Fantastic!
[applause]
I'm sure they’ll be happy
to chat with you at the break
about that work.
♪ (music) ♪